the only guy who's ever attracted to is
Justin Timberlake and I don't know
Justin Timberlake so I've never had an
opportunity i I know this guy a little
bit we've known each other since high
school
we go to the gym together so it'll be
interesting gym talk
I literally just met him like what ten
minutes ago ten minutes ago we'll get
beers afterwards yeah I don't know how
to how to feel I honestly don't know
what to do with my gum that's that's the
one thing I feel like there's been kind
of a tent this is like the Mulder and
Scully at the building towards this
moment be very conservative on the top
you swallowed your gum I did swallow
your retainer is not in my retainer is
in I don't know I don't think it's gonna
be that crazy to be honest but I'm the
older one so maybe I've been around he's
you know a sweet Midwest guy so you know
I'll take advantage of situation the
pretending he's a woman is probably not
gonna work too much he's got that full
beard so that's gonna be fun so do you
want to do like the tiptoes thing you
know making like this is good I
challenge you to find a fake tooth in my
mouth I know where it is we're just
gonna approach yeah which way both of us
no I want you to look deep in right yeah
yeah yeah
ah the beard was is interesting so it's
just a little scraggly wasn't so bad
I'm not gonna complain yet softer lips
and I oh well you know I'm still I'm
still young and tender really weird I'm
a good kisser
okay it's like a one step above a hug
you know once you were into it it wasn't
like weird it wasn't that different than
you know kissing anybody is just my
buddy
game a kiss that's it yeah I don't think
it's a big deal I think we need to chill
out
yeah if you were gonna kiss another guy
I wouldn't if you work would if you had
to kiss another guy would you rather be
me again cuz you know what you're
getting or would you want to kiss
another dood
I mean uh probably you again I kiss
someone else you got a window that just
kind of hurts I'm just saying you could
be better well I mean do you want go
practice